φιδα μο πιστεύολεότο ότι είσεσωσιοπαθείς πρέπει να τον επήραξετων το πράγμα διότι έστεε μου ένα
μήνυμα ν αγαπώσε και πουιτην υπέρα όύτε ξαναφανιστηκε μέσ πραι να μήνα των το πράπο
σου λέω πως ημιώθησε ναγια τα άτομα θα το γεντρόσομε γι τους αχαριστούς στο συγκεκριμένο
για τα άτομα που ενεργετήθηκαν που το χριστόφορό του τατα χρόνια τοτε επο χριστόφορος ήταν
στον πίκ του μεταλε ετάτουμετσε πάβλιστουμε α πράματα ήταν δίπλα κάποιο βουρούσαν ανδίπλα που το
χριστώφωνό γιατί νιώθαν και κάπως ναι πόση ιωθείς γιατότος που τη μια μέραν εξέένασε μεταεξηχαταηλέ
ον υκ μέσα στο διβλίο που έχο κεφάλιο για ότων τον πράγμα που το ονομάζως
είναι εξάρτηση μέα εμένα όλα αυτά τα χρόνια αγαθοεργείες μου ήταν σι συνεάρτεση που ήταν
αρώσκι ας πούμε είχιο ότι τα παραπάνω μου λευτά τώρα τα πάστις εφιλανθρωπίες α καταλάβεισείχα
βάν και φόρτν το ψηγεία μέσα πράματα και γύριζα εγί μου τα σπίθκια και ο
μήραζατουηγί πληνδίτο ελίτερο το τοάο λες ρεςπά έκαντα το χρόνια ότων το πράγμα αγορα ευτοκγίνητα
αναγενήσει σπιθιών ότι φαντα εί να με στη φυλακή να υκάλο εξοεαδεγαπένται άτομα έχανμπρα καταλάβεις
και τι έκα και στοτεος εκατάλαα ότι όταν ένας άνθρωπος βάλλει προστάτες ανάγκαι στον άλο
προστά που τ δικές του να ρωστώσ και ότό το πράγμα νο νομάζεται οτι πέντανισ
μεσ το ιβλέωμ εξηγότο είναι ίναι εξάρτηση των το πράγμα είχα τη ευτέραν πινική ν
υπόθεσς το ότικαστέρο για κάνιπτές επιταγές που τα κουμάρκα και την κυραγί νας που επράμου
στους εσπίτε και αλόγο πι όχει κια αλλήρε σε μια υτώ κ λιγογένει αςπουμε και
στο τέλος ξεστεκα τάλαβα από τούτα όλα γιατί βοήθεσα και έγραψάτο υποθεήσαν αυκού δημάρχει πεπ
επότο τους δημοτικής συμβούλιβουλευτές πρόεδρί της δημοκρατίας εβοήθησα λοιπόνκαι ξέρεις πως τους βλέπω επειδή επιδή
ξέρωτε α να με πληγώσου στο τέλος και ο πλέον τι λέ ότι άμανα αποφασίσεις
να βοηθήσεις κάποιο φίλεμου θα το κάμεις για σέν θα ο